hi everyone it's Jerry I have a
retrograde analysis problem I'd like to
share with you this is one I created
it's my first creation
for whatever the reason this popped into
my mind figured I'd share it
those of you who are fans of both chess
and math I think you may enjoy
retrograde analysis problems
if you're new to these types of problems
feel free to treat this as an
introduction
I'm a beginner with these so if the
problem comes off as Elementary
now you know why
with retrograde analysis problems we're
mostly concerned about what's possible
what's not possible we like to make
observations what certain
uh we're sort of like detectives we're
trying to figure out past events
so I'm calling this the king's capture
problem
a game of chess was played beginning
from this position that is without
Knights
the white king made a capture during the
game
and we eventually reach this final
position
the question is it possible black
maintains the right to Castle kingside
bear with me those of you who are
already experts in chess experts in
quotes
in order for black to maintain the right
to Castle kingside the king
and the King side Rook cannot have moved
and then we would have this little
maneuver where the King goes there and
The Rook goes here okay so with this in
mind uh now would be a good time if
you'd like to try and solve this go
ahead pause the video and when you
return I'll be sharing some words and of
course share
the solution with you
okay so given what we know we started
here
and ended up here
and somewhere in between we're told the
white king made a capture
what are some things we can say well
the capture had to be of a black pawn
it's the first thing you could be saying
another thing you could be asking well
how was the black Pond captured exactly
it couldn't have been captured on this
Square
because these pawns never moved and they
are controlling these squares which
means the king would never be able to
cross onto that square additionally
The Rook is defending the pawn so that's
another problem to try and figure out
so the black pawn must have moved
if it's here there's still a problem
there because it's defended with the
pawn this guy never moved so in order
for the black pawn to be captured it
needed to be on one of these three
squares that's something we can say
also we could look at this position and
say what is able to move
we have these pawns here that block in
the queen side Bishops and these pawns
Block in the king side Bishops
the Bishops didn't move we have Rooks
that could move the king that can move
anything else
how does the king
eventually go ahead and catch the pawn
so let's
run a test let's see
let's say
we go like this
black Pond is moving and we can't take
the pawn just yet we're trying to play a
legal game of chess it's defended by The
Rook this is illegal
maybe the king could go here
and now what can we do as black
in order to capture this Pawn
you may think
this Rook has to leave and now after the
pawn isn't defended we could take
and then the king could
do something like this get back to home
base and we reach this final position so
is the answer no it is not possible
black maintains the right to Castle
kingside
well not quite the answer to this
question is yes
and here's how it is possible
of course start out with F3
the king can approach like this and do
know that we have this new possibility
this guy doesn't necessarily have to
move
this guy has freedom of movement and can
go to B8
additionally there is one other piece
that could help
us to capture this Pawn successfully
legally
and that is the queen
she could pivot on E1
F2 where is she going exactly she's
going to H5
which now permits the white king to take
the pawn
and then we just simply tuck the pieces
back in to
home
base we reach the final position is it
possible black maintains the right to
Castle
yes
the king
the king side Rook
they didn't move so
the game plays out
this is how it could look
King site Castle is possible
anyhow again this is my first retrograde
analysis problem uh I'm looking forward
to you sharing some feedback how did you
do with this one is this something you
may want to see more of I don't know
it's the first of its kind at least on
this channel
any feedback is appreciated and yeah I
look forward to reading some of your
comments
that's all for now take care bye